hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen and welcome back to our
really fun how you think I would have
figured out the name of this series yet
maybe like some spooky snacks this is
probably gonna be the easiest thing that
I'm gonna make this week they are these
weird little teeth Apple they look like
this I really don't have any directions
so basically just gonna try to replicate
that I've got my apples and we're gonna
just we're gonna do it we're going to
cut them now we run with a peanut butter
in them
and then we're gonna make these little
smiles we've got our apples we've got
our peanut butter we've got our mini
marshmallows we got a knife
I work gosh I don't know what sport this
would be but I feel good about
everything that's happening brew ninja
ha okay so in like don't oh it just
looks like they've got little
marshmallows the teeth so take your
peanut butter and just lather it up here
on one of your sides more or less the
taste my friends
[Music]
you know what you do you boo-boo
Oh God
marshmallows are Cannavaro we're just
gonna stick these right here like teeth
I wonder what the directions really fit
I think this is brilliant
what a cute idea oh my goodness I love
it this is so dumb but so great these
are so silly this is the definition of
success success well guys thank you so
much for watching this is probably an
easy enough thing that I want you guys
to go out and make this and if you make
it tweet it to me
post it on instagram and let me know
what you think and see if you can do a
better job than me how good this would
hold goodness gracious oh ha ha ha
I'll try the peanut butter adolescent
Oh blossom alright guys see you later
happy Halloween I'll see you guys
tomorrow for another fun festive spooky
snacks bye Omar
[Music]
looks good to me okay well that's doing
that gonna stir some of the chocolate
and make sure it's looking good it's
actually looking really really good so
while the butter is melting we need
[Music]